i
[Música]
alarmante récords de cifras de kobe 19
en eeuu el país más afectado por la
pandemia superan las últimas 24 horas
200.000 nuevos contagios en mil
hospitalizaciones y más de 2800 muertos
una cantidad similar a los cerca de
3.000 estadounidenses que fallecieron en
los atentados del 11 de septiembre de
2001 los peores de la historia de ese
país tenemos reporte desde washington
la vacunación contra el cob y 19 en
francia será gratuita y comenzará en
enero para un millón de habitantes de
residencias de ancianos y proseguirá en
febrero para 14 millones de personas
vulnerables en total el país dispondrá
de unas 200 millones de dosis según el
primer ministro jan castex
hoy 3 de diciembre es el día
internacional de las personas con
discapacidad declarado en 1992 por la
asamblea general de naciones unidas con
el propósito de promover los derechos y
el bienestar de las personas con
capacidades diferentes
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se revelan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en eeuu en la unión
americana se registró un récord diario
de casos de fallecidos con 2.804 decesos
y más de 200.000 contagiados de kobe 19
superando así los 14 millones de casos
registrados hasta ahora los gobernadores
de los estados más afectados como
wisconsin y nebraska tratan de acudir a
las enfermeras en jubilación y también
de convencer a los estudiantes
universitarios que aún no han obtenido
sus licencias de que trabajen en
hospitales a cambio de tener créditos
académicos sus salarios deslumbrantes
los profesionales de la salud no dan
abasto con la magnitud de la emergencia
sanitaria en ese país para conocer más
la situación de la pandemia en eeuu
quiero saludar en este momento a nuestro
corresponsal en washington dice
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal los saludo
muy buena noche le pregunto cuál fue la
advertencia que hizo el director del
centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades en eeuu el doctor robert
brasil
rector dijo raúl que este invierno será
bastante gris que eeuu vivirá una de las
crisis de salud pública más grande en su
historia dijo además que además de estos
200.000 casos que se reportan al día en
febrero estos casos podrían llegar a los
450 mil casos diarios y es que raúl
además de los 2 mil 800 muertes que se
registran al día y las 200.000 casos de
kobe también registrados al día también
hay 100.000 estadounidenses que han
ingresado ayer lo hicieron a los
hospitales a las unidades de cuidado
intensivo esto ha hecho que estados como
california decreten un 'toque de queda'
le digan a sus ciudadanos que se queden
en casa sobre todo en áreas en donde los
hospitales pues ya llegan a el tope de
unidades de cuidados intensivos además
facebook facebook también dijo que
quitará de su página toda vez
información con respecto al comité
cristóbal y es que para hacer frente a
esta crisis sanitaria y sus efectos
económicos el congreso estaba debatiendo
un paquete de ayuda de cerca de un
billón de dólares le pregunto si se
lograra aprobar este paquete antes de
fin de este año
este paquete era de 14 billones de
dólares pero ahora será de 908 mil
millones de dólares los demócratas
bajaron este monto para poder que la
mayoría republicana en el senado y el
presidente trump puedan firmar esta ley
de paquete de ayuda lo que no quieren
los republicanos es que estos fondos
vayan a parar a los estados y con estos
fondos se pague un subsidio a los
desempleados pero ya nancy pelosi que es
la presidenta demócrata de la cámara de
representantes y el presidente del
senado mitch mcconnell hablaron hoy y
precisamente después de esta reunión
michoacano dijo que ve muy cerca un
acuerdo
donald trump también fue cuestionado hoy
al respecto y dijo que también ve muy
cerca un acuerdo el último acuerdo
paquete de ayuda que se firmó fue en
marzo este paquete fue de 2,2 billones
de dólares
cristóbal gracias por la información era
nuestro corresponsal en washington dice
cristóbal vázquez que tengo usted una
muy buena noche vamos ahora a ver cómo
está la situación de la pandemia en
algunos países europeos y en rusia en
italia se registró una récord de muertes
993 en 24 horas
mientras que reino unido superó los 60
mil muertos y rusia- contabilizó 580
muertes en la última jornada
seguimos en europa vamos hasta francia
donde el primer ministro jan castex
afirmó que su país dispondrá de 200
millones de dosis de vacuna contra el
coi 19 que va a beneficiar a 100
millones de personas ya que la vacuna
para que sea realmente efectiva requiere
dos inyecciones con unas semanas de
intervalo además de la vacunación contra
el cobre ona virus en francia- será
gratuita y comenzará en enero para un
millón de habitantes de residencias de
las personas de la tercera edad y luego
va a continuar en febrero para 14
millones de personas vulnerables
en un espejo al azar al final sólo
pagaremos por lo que realmente se nos
haya entregado la vacunación será
gratuita para todos es lo que el
gobierno ha presupuestado para este
propósito 1500 millones de euros en el
presupuesto de la seguridad social para
y ahora security social pudo emigrar
hacia el último de una serie de arrestos
el magnate de los medios de comunicación
de hong kong jimmy lai fue acusado este
jueves de fraude por un tribunal local y
también permanecerá en prisión
preventiva hasta su próxima audiencia en
abril del año que viene la y cuyo diario
fue allanado por la policía el pasado
agosto es un activista prodemocracia su
detención se suma a la del trío de
jóvenes encabezado por joseph wang que
fueron detenidos el miércoles por su
activismo marina esa riña nos amplia
el último de una serie de juicios contra
destacados críticos de beijing
jimmy lai el magnate de la prensa hong
kong esa creador de apple daily y
activista prodemocracia fue acusado este
jueves de fraude y permanecerá en
prisión preventiva hasta que la corte
dice una sentencia en abril de 2021 en
medio de una creciente represión contra
la disidencia la hay una de las voces
más fuertes a favor de la democracia
para el territorio semiautónomo se suma
a la lista de arrestos y condenas el
miércoles joshua won acne psoe iván land
fueron encarcelados por su activismo
queridos lectores es un día
particularmente utilicen los 25 años de
historia de nuestro periódico
enfrentando la represión nuestro
fundador jimmy lai seguirá bajo custodia
hasta abril del próximo año la ied de 71
años junto con otros dos ejecutivos
están acusados de defraudar a una
empresa gubernamental al incumplir un
acuerdo de alquiler de terrenos con las
oficinas de su periódico el pasado
agosto la policía hizo una redada en la
sede del tabloide por sospecha de
colusión con fuerzas extranjeras un
delito que con la nueva ley de seguridad
nacional de china podría castigarse con
hasta cadena perpetua además se les
acusó de
a grupos activistas prodemocráticos en
ese entonces las autoridades le
concedieron la libertad tras el pago de
una fianza 40 horas después docenas de
activistas prodemocracia y opositores
han sido arrestados bajo la polémica
norma china que puso fin a las masivas
movilizaciones en la es colonia y según
los críticos podría acabar con el futuro
del movimiento prodemocrático hong kong
et
y hoy les contamos la historia de juan
josé florián un colombiano que fue
obligado a ser parte de la ex guerrilla
de las farc cuando era menor de edad y
quien en un atentado contra su madre
perdió sus antebrazos una pierna y una
vista en un ojo su discapacidad no le
impidió convertirse en uno de los 30
atletas discapacitados más jóvenes del
mundo
el informe de andrea maya
todas las mañanas juan josé florián sale
a entrenar en esta bicicleta adaptada a
su cuerpo y con la que recorre cientos
de kilómetros
y su esposa es su entrenadora y también
su apoyo en la carretera juan jose fue
soldado del ejército de colombia pero
también uno de tantos menores de edad
reclutados por la guerrilla en julio de
2011 un paquete fue dejado en la casa de
su madre era una bomba enviada por las
farc producto de una extorsión
el explosivo detonó en las manos de juan
jose estuvo en coma le practicaron
múltiples cirugías duró un año en
rehabilitación física y durante este
proceso descubrió el ciclismo y el
placer de nadar
sueño con ser el campeón paralímpico
campeón del mundo
y ser campeón de las copas del mundo
está la ambición más grande que tengo
entonces por eso esa razón de entrenar y
exigirme cada día
al principio no fue fácil aceptar su
cuerpo e incluso un día pensó en que no
quería vivir más pero allí llegó a su
vida y formaron una familia ella lo
impulsa a salir todos los días e incluso
han creado una marca de material
deportivo yo quisiera que nosotros
transformamos un equipo muy grande
primero porque
nosotros el niño y yo lo apoyamos en eso
o sea a que él salga a todos los días
con alegría con pasión a hacer su
trabajo a montar en bicicleta
juanjo se acumula medallas de
competencias ganadas en años anteriores
su meta ahora es llegar a los
paralímpicos de toque en 2021 y si no lo
logra su objetivo será parís en 2024
y que así sea entonces hasta aquí el
informativo empresas 24 continúa con
nosotros feliz noche para todos
[Música]